[Music]
it's so excited about tour so how does
that how does the conversation go do you
text like emojis or does that have to go
through managers my tailor says you know
you're coming on to work me she was
telling me about it cuz we talk all the
time and you know for me it's a dream
come true because she knows like I think
when I first met her four years ago I
was like you know I really love you I
came up to her when at the VMAs and I
was like man I really look up to you you
really inspire me and she was one of the
people that made me want to start
songwriting so it's really amazing and
also you know with Charli XCX it's gonna
be I'm like really looking forward to
the door eggs you know it's gonna be
like a big like summer party which is so
similar because you are so independent
and powerful and you kind of stand for
the same things which I love so it's
gonna be an huge stadium so it's like
kids this is no small little feeder you
don't say one thing you have to take on
tour laptop headphones cinnamon toast
crunch mom Camilla Kibeho is gearing up
to tour with Taylor Swift but on Sunday
she rocked the red carpet solo at the
2018
I Heart Radio Music Awards just a week
after her big 21st birthday how did you
celebrate the big birthday I was uh I
was in Miami for the first half and then
I came here but it was really really
nice now I can and now you're officially
too busy to go to any after parties
because you have to get on your plane to
your next thing yeah yeah I know I don't
even want to go to after parties ooh now
I want to watch Netflix
[Music]
you
[Music]